[Music]
you you just shot 35 because i would
have got you jim but i have a feeling
that the big fella's free throw
percentage
is really much better
i saw that in the back earlier we are
going to allow you to redeem yourselves
and we look at the backboard here has
got the logos of all the teams you
played for
no no there's there's a line right
there's a line
right here this line
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's go let's go
enough you can actually you have your
choice your choice of balls balls right
here which one oh what that one you
don't want this one it's got a little
more i'll take the little balls on it
okay here's here here's the question
here's the question what how many
attempts will it take before he hits one
before hits what oh less than five yeah
less less three less three i say three
wait from there
which way is the line just this line oh
that's like oh no no maybe i know well
maybe five yeah seven over five
over five over five you go try that one
i i didn't know it was going to be that
far away
oh for two oh there you go here you go
way they're building the house over here
stop moving it man
you're building the house and shaking it
shake it up oh yeah that's great
you're over five hey don't worry i don't
know
remember to play
to play fan duels over under david hey
hey guys just hold up that episode of
law and order
hey
go for five level five let me go there
over six there you go there you go there
you go
man i've already killed two people
man just don't know don't he's going to
break the plex it's done with his
message hey
one for seven what's the center one one
for eight okay very nice not bad i'm
just messing with joe that bad yeah okay
that was entertaining i told you
i know what's gonna happen no no no no
no no don't break anything just come
here
i'll call you let's go quit
that's a wrap for inside the nba
presented
by kia
no
[Laughter]
for chuck and shaq and for kenny
we actually have uh a few days off here
yes hey here's with the snake don't run
kitty help me kenny help me please stay
here kenny
yeah yeah stay away from wildlife
homie diesel
don't joke about snakes man thanks again
to the bucks imperial circus for coming
by and entertaining us uh
with the burmese python everything else
drop something over there
[Music]
missed it yes he did
oh no but i think he was fouled send him
to the line
we got a playoff day off
we'll see you all sunday thanks crew
coming home i'm coming home oh you know
all right maybe we should have put the
put put your free throw along with the
football
wait what wait what chet hey gotta show
you gotta show you what happened earlier
[Applause]
y'all like that slant
don't run that slip right that's called
99 chuck
that sled right well hey corey randy why
are we missing shaq we're in a wrestling
race well last time shaq that belt
oh
[Laughter]
there we go
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what is going on you guys get paid a lot
of money for this tag me in touch
for free
good luck
here he goes
back and forth back [ __ ] one drop you
gotta drop it
roll
trump
[Laughter]
[Music]
good luck on saturday night good luck to
you guys in this room my goodness
i feel like i feel like sky low low in
here right
that's a new reprimanded reprimanded but
not suspended right you can't punch it
yeah
you know what the reprimand is check
five game suspension
this is you get a five game suspension
this was earlier today in the at the end
of our media conference call
so many games are very exciting
genuine believer on the nba dwayne casey
and there were a lot on
twitter from all sorts of different
sources about the raptors heavily
leaning its uh
steve i'm sorry casey's going to win
coach of the year most likely he's most
likely shaq to win coach of the year
how was it dwayne casey's fault that the
two best players on the team didn't
didn't show up i mean i don't know what
other way to put it it's not his fault
the one-two punch has not
stepped up and you know basically you
know they're going against lebron you
know i know a lot of players because of
certain people have never been able to
to get over that hump but
not the coach's fault you know he's
always been a guy that's been well
prepared he's well-liked he's well
respected but the players are the ones
that are out there on the court like you
know all the guys i played for they just
sat down and and
didn't scream and you know just kept it
quiet because they said you know what
we're not going to bail you out and you
know what you got to do shaq if you want
to be a champion when they start hacker
shocking i'm not bailing i'm not i'm not
taking you out and putting in samaki
walker go to the line of making i can
walk i see him a lot i know
so you
know i hope they don't fire him he's a
great coach but you know players have to
you know take it upon themselves and say
you know what
this is what we got to do back to the
next level and you know those two guys
they just you know couldn't couldn't get
past the king this year what i want to
say or
i think dwayne is a hell of a coach he
did a fantastic job and deserves coach
of the year yes
but uh-oh
he got he's got to repair his
relationship with demar derozan no no we
don't oh yes he does or he doesn't yeah
you have to because uh
that listen if your best player
you bent your best player why was he
benched uh he
well he that's not the point that's the
point you don't disrespect your best
player if you don't have a great
relationship with your best player
you're never going to win that's right
uh he did not that's not true well
in your opinion no just cause you say
something you're just that's not true
that's not true me and pat riley never
saw eye and what happened to my man win
so it's not true what you're saying
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter i was a role player
you're right but you know what that's
true
that's my point i'm saying
what's your best point you don't know
what you're talking about
period he got the repair he ain't got to
repair nothing you got to stop babying
your players you got baby that's why you
ain't win he got the pr i didn't have
duane i didn't have dwyane wade and
copyright carried me up and down the
court so why you know
because i got three finals mvp chuck
cause you google me
everybody google me
you see that yeah
you're a great player you don't know
what you know about when it comes you
know
he gotta step up and play you all didn't
have other players
on the court you can yell as much i got
three finals
i mean you are a great player thank you
you wouldn't have gotten if you don't
have calls
i will say i will say you got to stop
being i will say that
there is a stand that you take for you
like a guy's not playing well you bent
he
he did
have confidence in his bed but what i
think what charles is saying and what i
would believe as well
is when you don't play your best player
in those key moments you you also take
away
his his responsibility as the leader of
the team and so then he he becomes well
you're not the leader in the locker room
you're not the leader on the court and
so you could take that away from him
which he is your best player and for 82
games in the regular season he's going
to be it so when you take it away from
him that is a difficult situation that
at some point you have to address i
don't know about w if it means of
repairing it
but you definitely have to address to
address it you are the best player you
are expected to and you have to step up
if not
consequences let me ask you a question
if pop is coaching the raptors the way
that lowry and derozan played could they
have beat lebron hold on let's ashley
thank you for answering my question what
did popovich do this year with lamarcus
aldridge he was went and apologized
that that had to be done at le mans
chuck they hadn't played
attention
because
greg popovich is the best coach we got
in the nba today yes he was man enough
to say hey you know what lamarcus
i shouldn't have did it like that
that's why he's popovich and dwayne
kasich if he's ever going to get that
team back
he don't have to do it publicly or
something he gonna have to sit the mar
down and handle that situation
it's the exact same situation pop was
man enough to come out and say you know
what maybe i should try to do this
differently that's a difference
it's not what's different situation
what's a different situation bob said he
apologized for using him wrong when
you're a superstar you're expected to
step up and play at a certain level
everybody's done it you've done it mike
done it kenny done it in the finals you
got to play a certain way if you don't
play a certain way you get dealt with
accordingly and
like i say and if dwayne he's got to
address that derozan situation plain and
simple so we we agree he should keep his
job of course he does he's a great coach
all right the laker nation why listen
why are people so excited it's still
what i know but they just want to get at
you they just want to get me hey listen
i'm sticking with my pick hey dane
rub some icy hot on the shack right on
the uh ain't no shack right who was that
from laker nation my
okay well if the laker nation has a
distinguished gentleman to do something
i got to do it oh right why you got to
put your mask on yeah fix it apparently
he's going to stand up uh
and walk away feel good america okay
you're good yeah look good we don't see
your face oh
that's not even the broom if you break
that one shaq yeah i'll tell you man
that's not even the cheap provenance
hey y'all all excited y'all won a
game hey
don't you ever disrespect laker nation
you understand me
i got you like a nation always hey hey
he broke that for real wait y'all all
sisters y'all sent to this it's 1-1 you
don't know
hey hey look this is on camera four damn
lillard rubble little zorbine junior
put something sore junior is not going
to help at this location well listen
it's more of a muscle all black people
know if you put duct tape on something
it holds it together yeah that's how we
put our furnace together in the hood but
hey put some duct tape on it and you're
good to go dame i need
three more wins brother
why you always switch up like that you
said the lakers are getting swept oh
yeah i know it's
when you come out and say it's going to
be a sweep you got to expect come on i
got your leg relationship if you're out
there playing free basketball by
yourself step up for your brother
tonight defense me fence
first of all you're wrong i'm not wrong
shaq they got 73 points they're on
poster
they don't pay for 140
i don't care how many points you got as
long as you win the game y'all everybody
got to step up
yeah but first of all first of all i
speak from not being a great defensive
player but having championship
experience i know what the hell i'm
talking about the others got to step up
period i don't give a damn what you're
talking about hey listen listen rob hook
me up rob hey listen let me tell you
look me up rob thank you big shot bob i
appreciate you bishop roberto doria
jason uh uh james posey don't forget
when i got double triple three i'm
getting called away carrying your fat
ass so listen they got to play some
defense like he said they they gave up
70 points to a team that's missing rob
hook me up probably is five
four or five best players
come on now
come on man i i don't believe that i got
faith in uh he was not throwing out fake
hundred dollars bills with his face on
it no i don't believe that that's that's
not i cannot believe that no i don't
believe that hey i'm sure oh so you got
to defend yourself i do not believe you
again you got it bad uh sure if you did
i shouldn't do that i shouldn't do that
not the call right truck usher bucks
that's your bucks
you don't pay no bills that's your bucks
i know no
i don't know usher i'm just i i that's
what you heard what what's the story
because i i kind of heard this very
shack but he was out of here my ear
wasn't to the street all the way no he
was at a tablet store a grocery shop
they had a lot of groceries in there
chickens and wings
and chickens he was at a grocery store
and a song came on and he started making
it rain okay
and then one of
and them she she complained that it was
usher bucks yeah it was usher well if
you're you you can't get money
[Laughter]
you said it so convincingly you almost
had me no it is it is gross
it's a grocery store
you get legs thighs wings
that's where you go together it's a
grocery store
yeah but usually when you talk about top
five
you i don't want to say you must put
them in in position usually we talk
about top five guys are in position so
the fact that you had three centers in
your top five
it gave people i said you know a chance
to say well what about kobe what about
lebron i don't have a problem with your
list i have a problem with your list
chuck you ain't got me in the top ten
whatever you're smoking down in reno you
need to take it back to wherever you got
it from
second of all but yeah
okay if we say kill me
i'm not in your top
is not in your top 10. whenever you ever
see it now
i'm not blowing smoke because he's here
when have you ever seen anyone like shaq
i've never seen anybody like shaq
ever jack is the most dominant
big man ever in my opinion but
okay i put him behind magic and bird
lebron and kobe i didn't put it behind
nobody like crazy
like
no you didn't even say shot you did not
say shot yeah you didn't oh
you did not show my name at all no no no
i'm saying shaq is right there eleven
twelve thirteen
oh my god what else is that [ __ ] check
you kidding me
hey if you get chosen
every time
jack can i battle your audience
listen
every time you put shaquille o'neal next
to one not three four five
one
great player he won a championship
the big fella
and i see that you have some of your is
that your part of your wing over there
no this is my hawk nose i'm only going
to bring it out if we win chuck i'm
about to say something you never heard
me say before i'm good lopez is six for
six
in the paint yes in the paint so you
know last year i mean last game had 14
points in the paid in the first half
today they got 44 points you've been
saying this at all times no first three
games they did dominate the point but
last game we don't know what happened
right here jrue holiday bully ball
listen if you take take close shots high
percentage shots and most of the time
they're going to go in further you're
out from the basket if you're not
shooting well long rebounds other team
gets the rebound you got to stay in the
paint this guy right here is dominating
all right
i don't think i haven't seen him do that
in four or five years and right here the
sed the show oh my god
really dominating point but to again to
chuck's point
the hawks are around so i'm gonna put on
my lucky beak and i'm gonna give out the
call
let me hear it so they can hear me
oh
oh
oh
oh that's a muddy feet
a money beat that's right magic city
coming back home i didn't mean to give
it away i just noticed it sitting there
a bunch of chuck bucks with a what is
that an elastic
ear holder
all right so my guy eric so what's your
arts and crafts do you have a